- It is time to meet another Drew getter.
(chuckles)
Today we're shining a spotlight
on 10 year army veteran husband
and father of five Anthony Burrow.
I learned about Anthony
through the Kentucky Habitat for Humanity,
a nonprofit organization
that provides housing and services
to all veterans and civilians.
And he is overcome being homeless.
He has served in our
military state to state
and he was actively deployed in Iraq.
He is a hero and an inspiration to us all.
Please welcome Anthony Burrow
and his wife, Kara to the show.
(audience applauds)
Hi guys how are you?
- We're good.
- We're doing good.
- I'm really, really
excited to meet you guys.
And may I ask about,
with all that you do with being a veteran
and having children just managing it all,
when you're trying to find a home,
was there obstacles that you faced?
- Yeah as we were looking
for a larger house
'cause of having kids and such,
we realized there weren't many available
and our price range wasn't super high.
So we had to find what we could get.
It was a nice little fixer upper home
and found a nice little
small town that we liked.
That's about an hour from our hometown.
- And Kara, how did you hear
about Habitat for Humanity, Kentucky.
And what did they do with you guys?
- Our house was falling apart.
The floors were caving in.
I just felt like we weren't providing
a good home for our children.
So I started praying.
I actually went into our
pastor and I was like,
hey, I don't know what to do.
We can't get a house.
We can't stay in this house.
And the same night that I talked to her,
she said, well, Habitat's
accepting applications
for two more days,
maybe you should try it.
Thankfully, the director
of the habitat here
came out and he was like, you know what?
We're looking for veterans.
And I think we can help you.
- Keith was great.
He was really pro veteran
wanting to help work with us
every step of the way.
And I think we we started in what April
and by the following March,
they tore down the old house.
And then by August about
a year and a half later,
we had a new house.
(audience applauds)
- Anthony hadn't had a
childhood family home
to come home to yourself
and that consistent
concrete sort of beacon,
in the world that made you feel safe.
And you want that for your kids?
- Yeah most definitely.
My mom was pretty well, a single mother,
my biological father
wasn't around as such.
So there's a lot of things
that I never thought much of,
but I realized since then like
instead of focusing on the bad,
I can focus on I can do better.
What I can do that I wanted
and hopefully give to
my kids and do better.
- Anthony you served 10 Years in the army,
you both have five children.
How have you done it all?
- I think she's done most of it.
I just kind of been along for the ride.
- People would say, don't
you know how that happens?
And we're like, yeah,
actually we know exactly
how it happened a lot.
But we have a joke because
my daughter and ourselves,
we were praying.
'Cause it took there six years
in between our first and your second.
And we were praying and praying for a baby
and we always tell her,
well, you prayed for all these babies,
you kept praying.
And we kept praying and we got five.
- They were on back order that's all.
- And where do you stand
now with the mortgage?
- I think we've made two payments.
(both laugh)
- Chipping away at it.
I think the total, I think
is gonna be like 130,000,
but I mean for a brand new house,
a five bedroom for all
our kids, that is amazing.
- Well, it sounds like
you have a ways to go,
but our friends at the
Home Depot foundation
are dedicated to improving
the homes and lives
of US veterans.
And they've already invested
actually more than 350 million
in support of veterans in need.
So they're very much in line
with how important that is.
And Oh, I have to tell
you something actually,
Anthony and Kara,
that you won't have to worry
about another mortgage payment
because as a part of its
operation surprise campaign,
the home Depot foundation is
gonna pay off your mortgage
in full.
(audience applauds)
- What?
You're kidding, right?
- I'm not.
I will say that my entire
body is tingling right now
and I'm very excited to
be a part of this moment.
And it's really all about Home Depot.
I'm just really getting
to deliver the news
and I'm so honored to do so.
(audience applauds)
- That is awesome thank you.
- Oh, I'm so happy for both of you.
You both deserve this.
And what you wanna do for your children,
have that place that they
can go back to as adults
and pull back on the memories
and continue to create new ones.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- This doesn't happen to us.
So just, wow thank you all.
Thank you Home Depot foundation.
Thank you Drew Barrymore Show
Thank you Habitat.
- Well deserved.
Thank you, Anthony and Kara so much
to you and your beautiful five children.
Welcome home.
- Thank you.
- [Drew] We'll see you soon.